there were thousands of girls 12 and 13
years old who made tapes across the
country and I saw several hundred of the
tapes and I personally interviewed at
least a 100 and there came a time when I
thought we're not going to be able to
make this film with a 12 or 13-year-old
girl it was impossible for a lot of
reasons uh not least of which was what
was this going to do to a child after
performing an experience like that my
assistant buzzed me and said there's a
woman out here named Eleanor Blair and
uh she's brought her daughter she
doesn't have an appointment would you
see her and I said why not the second
Linda Blair walked in the door I knew it
was her I just knew it